hey guys welcome back to the very last
Evan and Kailyn podcast you'll ever
listen to this decade we won't get a
chance to say that for another ten years
I don't know but today we're gonna be
looking back at 2019 we're gonna be
giving some life updates we're gonna be
sharing some of our thoughts on alright
I thought you you inhales I expected
some truths and we're gonna play the
Christmas Carol Matt lives flashbacks to
Evan the bacon man okay so catching up
on life stuff we have had a very
interesting past three weeks or so ever
since we kind of caught up on the last
crazy bit of video that we've committed
to we kind of had a little bit of time
to tackle things have been building up
for the past year or more yeah I don't
want to get into it there's like a lot
of things that aren't really good for
content Caitlin has been doing a lot of
tax yes much tax it's very taxing good
joke and we've also been catching up on
a lot of backend stuff you know we
started a discord server and then did
nothing with it and things you know
needed to be taken care of they're just
stuff around the house has literally
been piling up or just waiting there
staring at us guilting us like realize
we haven't changed our air filters in
two years you're supposed to do it every
90 days two years it was a year and a
half okay but it was way too long so
we've just been doing a lot of things
like that around the house like there's
there's office of those like typical
things that I'm sure most people have in
their house that just like you see it
and you know that it's wrong you know
that you should do something about it
and we just haven't like there's this
garden hose we hooked up to our backyard
and I've tried taking it off so many
times
and it's just like we didn't just dealt
with it it hasn't been actively
bothering us but we know that it's
getting worse the longer we let it sit
there it gets more stack it gets more
suck so I had to cut that apart we
drained the water heater and it was bad
it was so bad music I don't I don't want
to go into all of the things we've been
doing all of the things we've been
neglecting cuz it's kind of slightly
embarrassing because we are kind of like
you know we're a DIY channel it's like
you can do this and you can totally
can't do this but we've been putting all
of that effort towards things that will
make for good videos and draining the
water heater isn't the most like woah
clickable that's so clickable you won't
believe what happens thing we broke our
valve and our hearts so there's a lot of
that but we can move on from that let's
let's talk about other updates around
our main channel I think that the big
thing that we kind of aren't thinking
about right now is we have slowed down
the pace of our video releases we've
been taking a few more buffer weeks to
get caught up on all the stuff it's been
building up the past two years I think
that it's it's shown us that we need to
do that more instead of letting the
things build up to the point where
things are literally really bad and then
taking a longer break to deal with all
of them in one big chunk like we've done
starting in December and it's gonna
continue into January it'd probably be
better to proactively fit these little
breaks in so that these things don't
just build up yeah so we can actually
like take care of life stuff so we don't
know what our schedules gonna be you
know it has been weekly for the longest
period of time for a long time about
halfway through this year we started
taking buffer weeks so we would do three
or four a month instead of four I think
it was like with your food in four and
then we'll take a break and then we'll
do four and I'll take a break then we
like just recently started doing three
than a break and I think that we might
do two or one than a break
around this area just because we don't
have time because I don't know we don't
want to talk about too much because
we've already touched on a lot of these
things like why we don't outsource
because we kind of like doing what we're
doing and we don't know I kind of rehash
the same things over and over again but
we I think we've realized that we might
need to slow down our video production a
bit until things are good and then we
can ramp it up to whatever is a
sustainable pace you know so we're gonna
be doing with some rebalancing and you
know what I shouldn't have talked about
all of that because we're gonna do a
whole what we're looking forward to in
2020 episode okay we'll go into more
detail about 2020 in the neck we're in
2020 yeah any other details before we
look back on 2019 I think one thing
that's pretty exciting I have an update
what's an update oh yeah Caitlyn has
been like I have something cool to show
you that's like been her new like
distraction thing well so okay so it did
not I did not set out to get addicted to
tick tock I set out cuz it was like you
know what everyone's getting on tick
tock
we should really maybe consider getting
on tick tock we avoided getting on
snapchat we never did that but you know
what like tick tock it's just I just see
a lot of people getting on everyone's
talking about it so like I made an
account I reserved our handle there's
nothing there don't bother right now but
I like reserved it so that I could just
stalk people you know or just knows
what's out there it's not really stock
people I don't really know how to stock
people it's just like see what it feeds
you yeah and see what's like doing well
and everything yes cuz anything it feeds
you with stuff that's doing well
supposedly and see like what the trends
are cuz it's very trend based yeah it's
very like like these trends will just
happen based on like songs or like
certain way people do things like
they'll point and text will pop up at a
certain point you know and there's all
these like patterns that people follow
and build off of each other and I was
like okay I need to like study this
see well and anyway so I started like
watching a bunch of them and then as you
watch them it starts learning like what
you stay on I guess I've never liked
anything so I don't know how its
learning other than just love like what
I've passed versus what I've watched
algorithm yeah but it's starting to
learn because now it's like half cat
videos so by the time I log in on our
shared accounts are gonna be finally
there's gonna be a finely tuned machine
it's cat videos and then people doing
the wow you can really dance which I'm
sorry anyone who does not watch
tick-tock doesn't know what that is also
see was like like any song and that's a
trend gets really stuck in your head oh
it's so stuck in my head I like I I'm
having a hard time falling asleep
tick-tock songs in your head yes well
and then I keep thinking like okay so if
we were gonna do one like we were gonna
hop on that song tree yeah how would we
do it so it's almost like it seems like
one of the dangers of tick tock is is
there's time pressure time pressure you
mean like for us well there's like tire
pressure for the trend it's like oh
trends happening we got to do something
like wall the trend is still good
otherwise it's gonna be lame no I don't
really think so
because there's an unlimited there's
unlimited trends mm-hm
that's true yeah and there's also like
there's so I thought it would be like
mostly high school students and stuff it
seems the youngsters the uses but
there's a decent amount and again maybe
it's just like whatever yeah but there's
a decent out of people like in their 20s
and 30s as well on there um so I think
that's a like it's interesting cuz you
can there's people like making fun of
themselves like reasons why I shouldn't
be on tick-tock I'm 33
I have kids you know it's stuff like
that and that made me feel like less
pressure because people are like making
fun of themselves yeah for not being the
typical tikka tacos because at first I
was like I don't know a lot younger than
us
I don't know so it was a maybe we'll
just start putting contact that content
out there and trust that the tick-tock
algorithm will know who to show it to
maybe I think I think one reason I'm
also thinking about it is cuz like some
of the trends do look really fun to do
mmm like not that we really have time
it's the kind of thing that like if
anyone who's listening I just realized I
would hmm and as I kind of stared
blankly like not that excited I'm not
excited it's just like time I know time
and I worry we have so much already on
our plates that like here's here's the
difference it's kind of like and maybe
this is just cuz I'm watching them like
it looks fun to do
mm-hmm Timmy so maybe we'll try it at
some unknown point we'll put some tic
TOCs out there see if anything happens
and then just like we'll play it by ear
yeah yeah because we're already like
ramping up on other things like that the
gaming channel is still going nicely we
just hired on not hired on we found and
contracted another editor to help
content for my neighbors helping us
create really awesome videos and they're
they're so awesome over there but uh
yeah we have a lot a lot has changed in
2019 a lot has changed good segue good
what we're talking about now Halon
looked up some numbers I want to hear
numbers only here are the numbers that
you looked up and how much like like the
sub count has changed the views we might
get per video and how many total views
have changed okay so yeah so I guess
like first off the one of the main
topics of this podcast is like looking
back on 2019 is not a good place to
start would be some of the like concrete
numbers yes like okay known things okay
do you remember what our subs were at in
January of 2019
I mean IIIi do only because I looked at
today like we talked about doing this my
guess is somewhere around
one hundred and seventy eight thousand
one hundred and seventy two thousand wow
what a good guess I have but yeah so
January 2019 so the beginning of last
year we were at a hundred seventy two
thousand and we're ending the year at
five hundred twenty thousand that was
our goal we hoped to hit five hundred we
would hit five hundred by the end of
year that was like are like wow that'd
be so cool if that happened there's a
while or I didn't think it wouldn't yeah
and we surpassed past good job I'm
shaking Caitlin's hand for the audio
only listeners well hey let's do the
high five for people who are just
listening yeah so that was our change in
subs our total video views' this I'm
really curious about um do you want to
guess what we were in January of last
year or this year five million at the
beginning and 20 million by the end in
the beginning we are at 7.9 million
uh-huh the end you said 20 where we are
currently at forty one point five
million wait from seven to forty one
yeah I'm like wait is that right no
that's right that's cool that's crazy
right cuz like this has been our biggest
year so far by far obviously you know
you know the more you you the bigger you
are the faster you grow we've seen to a
certain degree our first year in 2017 we
started in March we ended the year
around like 30 something or 40 is about
40,000 and then 2018 we went from forty
thousand to one hundred seventy two
thousand which was like pretty big over
a hundred thousand in a year but then
this one 172 to 520 that's like decent
chunk yeah and I definitely want it it's
our goal in 2020 to hit a million that's
you know it's it's its algorithm it's
kind of a weird goal it's not really
goal
because it's like it's like you said you
only have so much control over it it's
like our hope it's like why do we even
do that like I don't know five hundred
thousand this gap is bad for our mental
health I know it's like but like you
know you can't help but like it's like
don't do that but you know you are yeah
I know I am don't check your subs every
day
I haven't I've been doing so good I
haven't checked ourselves too much
paycheck recently it's been kind of slow
slow yeah we haven't put on it and we
haven't had like a real banger in a
while yeah I don't like from until like
three videos ago okay
I've one more interesting stat yes this
one's different because it's not like a
total mm-hmm it's an average so a lot of
like I well because then and the main
thing that matters is how many views the
video gets and being able to be
consistent there is it's really
important yes I'm talking about averages
average views um so in 30 days how many
views do you think our videos in January
of this year we're getting 20 to 30 50
50 50 that's pretty good pretty good
um uh so January 2019 we did five videos
in January by the way we're pretty much
like slackers now I know so that was
50,000 years now what do you think our
last five videos and the past two are
not 30 days old yet I would guess pretty
good over 300 372 kb is is our average
not that's really good that one's like
yeah that one's pretty crazy I mean I'm
trying to kind of like wrap my head
around that cuz I feel like it went up
proportionally more proportionately more
than our sub count yeah I haven't done
the math on that you know I was trying
to do it in my head but I realized that
that's too complicated but it's good I
get a good feeling about that yeah it's
crazy
definitely not let it follow otherwise
we're gonna doubt our silly
oh yeah this is crazy
like we don't we don't talk about it
much cuz we don't I mean we talk about
it to each other but we don't like talk
about it oh you're gonna knock that
light over it's tilting okay thank you
we don't talk about it much probably
publicly cuz like we don't want it to
come off like we're trying to like brag
about growth or anything like that but
like it is kind of crazy to me just cuz
you don't you don't like going to this
really knowing what to expect you know
and we're just hoping to like be
financially successful enough that we
can work together yeah make it worth
they could pay the bills and everything
like that yeah and we were hoping that
it was gonna slow down yeah I think we
thought we'd like not be working as much
if it weren't for the additional things
that we were doing I think that we would
be kind of I still believe in the long
term value of those two ventures that
we're doing I mean we started it for a
long-term vision and you know it's
rolling the baha we're here we've made
14 almost a year until the end of the
podcast we've only taken a few weeks off
ideals do still really enjoy talking
with you I think that's like with you
too the main thing that like increase
the corn more corn please
corn is our shorthand for corny but I
think that that is the thing that like
really I do it for you guys to the
people who tuned in and listen and rate
and review thank you guys but I mean
like I think that one of the main thing
that like really gets me like motivated
to keep on doing the podcast is talking
with you and I know that we hang out and
talk every day but but I still want more
yeah it's a nice weekly kind of check in
between the two of us yeah on things and
it's fun like our games yeah I'm excited
for you know continuing to develop the
podcast and the things that we'll look
forward to like I've really been
enjoying like chatting about YouTube
with you like discussing the drama like
what's happening now is our livelihood
gonna go away no like you know just
having an excuse to like do those deep
dives and research those things and
share with you and discuss it and you
know share it with you guys to her
listening yeah that brings me an
enjoyment so I think how have things
changed this year anything like really
noticeable I mean I know that we already
talked about the podcast and gaming I
think those are the two biggest changes
yeah I think another one is and we kind
of touched on it because we mentioned
not wanting to outsource but another one
is outsourcing like because outsourcing
the stuff we don't want to do oh to a
certain degree I don't think it's that I
think it's just outsourcing the stuff
that wouldn't it's a mixture of stuff
that wouldn't happen if we didn't
outsource it
yeah or stuff that like we need to
outsource it in order to be responsible
so what I'm talking about is hiring the
gaming editors to help us work on the
gaming channel because those edits just
wouldn't happen otherwise it just
wouldn't exist what exists there's just
no more no more time yeah so you know it
would just be so time-consuming to have
that all just on us
something's like you know we're not
experts at everything so Caitlyn has
been you know talking to an accountant
and getting some help there and all the
financial accountant were finally adults
advising us to do this for a long time
and I have been stubborn because I was
like yeah but we finally hired an
accountant we like talk to a financial
adviser to set up retirement accounts
cuz we don't have a company matching
contributions you know it's like we
gotta figure that stuff out so I think
that was like a big change for 2019
getting more and more legit on the
business side of things well no just
like hiring help yeah also figuring out
what it makes sense to hire out and what
it makes sense is not do there's a lot
of things we abandoned like if you go
back and look at some of our older blog
posts after we started making YouTube
videos we dried out the whole tutorial
would pull pictures for everything would
write Instructables and those really did
help us at the beginning of our youtube
career you know that that time really
did pay back in terms of growth and
everything but at this point that the
time it takes to do that it just like
doesn't make any sense at all to for us
to still take that time ourselves and
we've tried outsourcing it it didn't
work well it didn't work well and also
just like it wasn't worth the time and
money like at this point yeah so I think
there was another thing we just like
eliminated things and then one thing
this wasn't really something we
eliminated it's just something we kind
of took a little bit of a break from and
that was collaborations caused a huge
thing of travel and and travel for
events a huge thing of 2018 was we just
said yes and pursued every opportunity
so like we went to literally every event
we fit in as many collaborations as we
can and I'm so glad that we did that
yeah but like this year with the
starting of the two additional channels
and just trying to like not burn out
because travel is super tiring we we did
we did a couple events this year we
dream we did
two year-long collaborations between two
really up-and-coming YouTube channels
Evan and Caitlin gaming podcast yeah
we've even given them shoutouts
shoutouts like crazy like crazy like
almost every one of our videos we give
them a shout outs and like when have
they given us a shout out never you know
what hey guys
go over to youtube.com slash evident
Aten I hear those guys are great they've
been killing it this year have been like
collaborating with ourselves it has been
kind of like the main thing we've been
doing this year we have been putting in
a lot of time and effort into and like
oh man like starting the uncut Channel
all the time and effort that went into
that and everything yeah yeah
so that would that that's a pretty big
difference between now and and 2018 and
I we do have some potential collabs for
2020 nothing's like 100% set in stone
yet and I am excited to do some collabs
again but I think we just needed this
year to like focus on like refining our
style and building up these other things
we were starting what was one of your
proudest moments 20:19 I mean there's
been a lot of like specific videos I've
been really proud of and like hitting
500,000 was pretty like once you the
moment you hit it it's not it's not
really about like the moment yeah
because it's kind of like having a
birthday you know it's like you're just
like yeah you know but um that was
pretty cool I also seem to like I don't
know why but when we you know we always
were thinking okay when we reach this
sub counter that and statistic or that
whatever will feel more secure it will
feel more relaxed and and everything and
it didn't really happen until half a
million subscribers but I think it's
something more than that
I have one I have two moments in
particular that really stand out to me
this year but anything else that really
stands out to you I want to hear it
yours okay my two moments this year that
like really got me is that you know it
wasn't like exactly a single moment but
it was enough of a moment that like
these these two points stand out to me
one is at the beginning of this year we
were stumbling in January mm-hmm
you know and when did we start picking
it up again with the spin-art and night
in March and that strong period lasted
like three months for three months like
so in the beginning of this year we
transformed we know like like we've
talked about before we kind of shifted a
little bit more towards entertainment
and we found our footing and we we we
did really good for a little bit and
then there is a stumbly period for a
period of time and then we're man did we
lose it to be push it too far did we
like are the projects we're selecting
not doing well or whatever and then we
found it again yeah during some month
October November and then like those
months were like really doing it you
know and I think that going through that
cycle multiple times it was like when it
was probably the second or third video
we did in the in that September period
October November that like second or
third video in that period I remember
thinking okay that's this is just how it
is it's a cycle you know we might our
videos might slow down for a bit and
then they're gonna pick up again in a
bit and that's when I kind of really
started to trust that feeling that I had
been telling myself for a long time and
then like you know this period we're in
right now it is a little bit slower but
you know we're still healthy I feel you
know our average views is doing well all
of that but I think that like I just
trust that we can pick up again we can
hit that video we can hit that whatever
and things will like move again and I
just believe in it I always told myself
it but I always doubted and I think that
there is a moment
this year during that second good period
really okay I believe I believe we can
chunk exactly so that was moment number
one that was a really big moment for me
because it made me a lot less stressed
the second moment today of 2019 was
earlier this year I I really wanted to
start the gaming channel yeah in in in
the beginning of 2019 and Caitlin was
like on a game I just doubted like if we
have the capacity to kind of like my
reaction to Caitlin mentioning tick-tock
it's like I support you I'm gonna do it
I believe in you I'm excited like you
add some here you're gonna have to
subtract here mm-hmm it's just the
reality of our life right now and and I
understood Caitlin's hesitation to you
know I I'd you know like you know we'll
try it and if it's not good well ditch
it but she believed in me and we started
gaming and we really liked it and we had
a lot of fun and and some of you guys
joined us which meant a ton and it has
been growing and I don't know when I
think it's when we first started putting
out our Minecraft videos by like the
second or third minecraft video we were
really getting into minecraft and this
audience that liked watching us play
minecraft was like really finding us and
you know I felt like our subs were
really healthy for our size and things
are going on the gaming channel and I
don't know what exact moment was but I
think those shortly after we started
playing Minecraft on Evan and Caitlin
gaming I'm like oh yeah this is
happening let's have some momentum this
has a future like my gut feeling inside
like had some truth behind it and I like
started
thing and believing in it too and I
think that's when I was like yeah I
don't know I have a similar thing for
the for the gaming channel and again
it's like it's it's not really a
specific moment but I did have that same
kind of feeling and it was like maybe
like five or so like streams into
Minecraft uh-huh
when I started realizing like week I
don't know I just I just felt like we
were starting to build like a community
I think part of it also is like before
that we would just play one-off games
here and there
yeah it's kind of hard and we were still
trying to like figure out what types of
games worked well for streams and things
like that like how to balance playing
the game and like being able to chat
with the people there and I feel like we
kind of like started hitting strides
with Minecraft and it was a game we both
really liked and it's a game that like
you can kind of just play forever which
I really really like that and I kind of
had a similar feeling and I can't say
exactly what it was and I think but I
think for me
part of it was spurred by like and I
don't know what the exact number but
like when we started realizing that like
there's a lot of people hanging out with
us I think I started getting this 50 or
60 or 75 that I was like wow and I was
like dang this is like a lot of people
came in the chat was starting to move a
little bit more and everything they
started developing like they were like
inside jokes you know that were like you
only get it if you're like hanging out
in the live streams or if you watch the
gaming videos you know it started
becoming its own independent started
becoming its own independent thing and
like that was such a cool feeling and
it's like you know we kind of had that
feeling when we built up Evan and
Caitlin and it started becoming a thing
and like you know your things just kind
of naturally develop of course it yeah
and so when that started happening with
with the gaming stuff and most of it
like around
Minecraft's it was really cool and
exciting and I am I'm really glad that
you pushed to hire out the editing cuz
the first couple of videos like you
edited knew like and I didn't have
enough time to really put the love and
care that are out of theirs like yours
are okay they were they weren't great
they weren't great and like you know I
was doing the main channel videos and it
was like we wouldn't have time but I was
really hesitant to hire it out cuz you
know in my brain I'm like the gaming
channel doesn't make any money it's
we're almost breaking even now almost
but it was kind of like do you know in
my brain I'm trying to be practical I'm
like why would we put money into this
and like higher stuff out it's not it's
not doing anything and there's no proof
that it'll grow but like I'm really glad
that you kind of push to try it and I'm
I'm just like really proud of where the
gaming channel yes I'm really proud of
our main channel - yeah I mean the only
reason why we have a gaming channel we
realize that yeah that's what we are
everything - yeah 100% I will say
another thing again this isn't really
like a specific moment maybe we
shouldn't awarded it like proudest
moments of their their moments in time
even though they may span weeks that's
Jim I think another saying for me for
2019 oh by the way I just have to like
say when I'm reaching over here you
can't see it but supervisors in my lab
Evans not just like petting my leg I was
like it was like looking over here and
she looks back at me she's so sleepy
right now and when she gets sleepy she's
like like loves being pet oh yeah
most times she's okay with it but when
she's really sleepy she just loves that
and she looks up at you just like I like
this pet and it just donkey
so it's like there's a moat where I was
like looking over you no one can see
this even the people watching the video
they're just out of screen but Jesus the
cutest little thing yes so that's what I
was down but yes I think I think one
thing one of my like hopes for 2019
going into it was to try varying up our
projects a little bit more and like test
out doing things that are maybe a little
bit more on like the art side or like
try things that are a little bit more on
the crafty side oh my gosh she's like -
loving those tin scratches um and it was
something that we were kind of hesitant
before because it was like we're make
our channel and there's a little bit of
a weird like like may sometimes make her
channels don't want you to like call
them a crafting channel they're like a
maker Channel they build things and
there's a little bit of like I don't
know it felt like crafting channels were
crafting channels in maker maker
channels you know and it was like it
felt kind of weird doing stuff that was
like a little bit lighter on the making
side I don't know could it maybe bust
out a saw no matter what but one of the
things for 2019 was we did try doing
stuff that like didn't have power tools
at all just like the art videos like Bob
Ross I think the very first Bob Ross
okay when we published Bob Ross and it
didn't tank that was a huge moment for
us I remember okay
specific moment I remember we were just
like a little bit stressed and we're
like okay let's take a little break
let's go to Benihana let's have a long
lunch and let's talk about the future
and I think that one of the things we
talked about is like you know what when
we can just make a bob ross following
the bob ross tutorial video and we like
publish that on Evan and Caitlin the
main channel well know that we're doing
right and we're like on the path that we
want to be on and then really you know
what let's just do it
yeah let's do it and I remember like we
were we
- Benihana we came back we were on the
patio we were just chatting and like
trying to figure out the future I
remember that moment we're like you know
what let's do it and then we did it and
it didn't do horribly it did okay it did
okay lower end of the scale but it
didn't completely tank it past a certain
threshold for us and okay yeah and then
we've done a second one since then and
it did okay I did okay but but included
and that was also like the acrylic pour
videos we call it pour videos thus the
spin art video the soap making videos
like those are all kind of like lighter
on the making side like they don't
involve a bunch of power tools and that
was something that we just we were
worried wouldn't perform well but we
really wanted to expand the type of
videos we did and that's something that
we tried doing I think that you know
pushing ourselves in that direction
really helped another thing that's
interesting is oh and also just before
we move on it wasn't just like a fear in
our heads like the videos that we had
done that we had tried doing a little
bit like craftier or more artistic we
had a DIY art video we had like the
Halloween ghost video which was just
crafty we had a few it was bad they did
they did bad like not like acceptable
but like below the level that we felt
was acceptable can we not do this like
can we do crafty or type project like we
like them we just had to like change the
format a little bit change like the
title and thumbnail make it like more
you that's true you know that's true but
yeah so that's one thing I'm like all
that to say one thing I'm very proud of
is like the ability to expand the types
of projects we're doing and I see us
like potentially continuing that every
time we push ourselves in a new
direction we learn something new we pick
up a thing we can bring back to benefit
our channels as a whole for example when
we live stream the video games we play
we are chatting them
each other more we're engaging with the
live audience we have developed certain
skills that will help us long term not
just with streaming but I feel like
sometimes Kaitlyn and I when we're
painting or we're doing resin force or
we're doing whatever we have to like
keep up a certain energy we have to keep
up a certain pace to get good content
that peeling can turn it into it at it
because if we're like all right time for
resin pour and we just went into full
concentration Road there wouldn't be any
good moments I think that you know we've
picked up some things from performing
live to our gaming audience and we've
brought that into how we film for our
main channel and then also you know as
we've brought on more editors and
defined our editing style for Evan Kalin
gaming you have brought in a lot of that
into our main channel I'm like yeah I've
definitely been inspired by the gaming
editors and brought in bits of that to
the to the main channel you know like
there's so much better at memes and I'll
bring in like like old YouTube clips
like keyboard cat stuff was just things
in general but also like cutting things
at the right moment cutting things to
add more humor and everything like that
and as we've you know as we've brought
on more editors we try to define our
style and I think that when you try to
teach something you do learn it yourself
even more so as we've brought on editors
we have this this master sheet that
we've worked been working on of like how
to add humor how to tell a story or you
want to focus on what type of music how
to set a standard intro and outro and
all of those things that we had to do
for the gaming editors we realize we can
do some of that for our main channel too
like the the standard intro and outro we
don't want to do that for all of our
content doing series series to series no
yeah
DOI Ruiz and
and the virus yeah diversity I think we
will get on two of each yeah but you
know two counselors in the series and we
have more planned of each yeah so there
I really know where I was going with
that yeah
oboe other things other things that
we've learned and then that have
benefited us in multiple ways like this
set up the green screen behind us the
lighting that we have here like that
really makes our skits better faster
more efficient for us to make and and
better for you guys to watch hopefully
it allows us to only spend money on one
costume and the reporter solve
separately and then edit them together
but these are things that we got from
the gaming channel and podcasts yeah
everything kind of like symbiotes
together some bytes in a very
interesting way and everything kind of
feeds off of each other and benefits off
of each other and I think that's a
really cool thing that I didn't really
see coming when we started down all
these paths that's another big thing
looking back on 2019 that I'm like
really realizing more and more yeah are
there like any particular struggles that
stand out that were kind of like new
struggles that we hadn't faced I have
two in particular which ones a month a
month ago we were in like a bad place
yeah it was bad we just over committed I
don't want to talk about too much
because I feel like we've brought it up
many times but realizing how to not over
commit realizing like you know because
we've had a schedule for a long time but
you know we started working with
different types of sponsors that have
different requirements we've started
kind of you know like every Friday is
launch day and sometimes we do a podcast
or we stream it's not like there are
seven days a week that we can work on
main content video anymore there's like
it's not like because we used to work
seven days a week 12 hours a day on Evan
and Caitlin and now it's like
six days a week like eight hours a day
and then the other hours and the days
and the other days we're working on like
podcasts and gaming and stuff so it's
just it's just we just don't have enough
time we don't have as much time to
dedicate towards main videos and I think
that we're kind of readjusting and
re-evaluating how to schedule ourselves
and how to be realistic and how far
ahead we want to be and and all of that
Oh a lot of stuff learned but the
biggest struggle was definitely during
that period I got tired I think that our
content might have suffered a little bit
interestingly I feel like you're a
Content didn't really that were like you
guys look really tired oh we got a ton
of comments of people saying we looked
tired but I was so good you guys the
content was still good and I think like
we just had some really good ideas some
big ambitious ideas and we executed them
well and we like did the work but there
are definitely times like I call it like
getting rayji where I get unreasonably
mad when anything bad goes wrong is like
I'm a happy person yeah most of the time
but when things are bad I I can get
upset and I I you know I think I
communicate it well I'm like Caitlin I'm
just kind of upset right now a little
bit of space in the garage all alone
don't like this thing I just need a
power through I love you I'll see you in
a few hours yeah so it's like you know
it didn't affect our relationship in any
bad ways you know our good communication
skills as well edit together we were on
the same team we always knew that but
like there were moments where I wasn't
happy there were moments where you
weren't happy there are moments where we
were just like well this is just how
things are and we just have to get
through it yeah there are two months of
that and and you know I think that if
from the outside perspective it might be
kind of
attempting to say well just don't do it
like say no to that sponsor or turn down
this opportunity or whatever but one
thing that we're doing behind the scenes
is we're building relationships with
these companies with these agencies with
our reputation on the other end like one
reputation we're building up with is
with you guys but we have lots of
business reputations we're building on
the back end and we don't want to be
have a reputation as people who back out
of deals who mess up people's budgets
the mess in people's like plans like if
we if we had have backed out of those
deals we would have made someone's day
really difficult on their end and that
would have gone up the chain or gone
down the chain to ground sideways or
they could have moved or like it's just
that's not what we want to be yeah I
think the argument is you you just don't
say yes in the first place but I think
one of the things that like people also
don't realize is like I know we use this
analogy a lot but it's like Wild West
like so we might say yes to things for a
schedule that's reasonable but then
because one sponsor has to change
something then everything has to get
shuffled around with everybody and then
all of a sudden you're filming six
videos in a month where you're only
releasing three but you gotta film six
you know things like that
sixty percent of our income so we kind
of need that revenue and you know when
we shuffle things around we have to like
bring someone else in and that's a big
to do that I don't think is is the sexy
thing to show or or talk about too much
you know that's just part of the backend
of business for us that's just our
reality it's interesting because like we
when we first started working with
sponsors we went through a period it was
actually October of 2018 I remember very
specifically where that's where we were
in the period of just kind of like
saying yes like and like and it was all
companies that we were like legit super
excited to work with and we're like
my gosh they wouldn't quit that's not so
cool yeah totally oh my gosh they want
to work with us too and then we were
doing six videos and it was it was crazy
yeah and it like we kind of fell into
the same trap for different reasons the
SONA it was more because of like
scheduling issues it wouldn't have been
over committing a little bit of a
scheduling fluke yeah a little bit of
like scheduling flukes like a few things
it's just kind of happened to like all
line up the wrong ways but I think I do
think it it taught us like but because
we had been getting our schedule to a
better and better and better place what
kind of crazy those past events and I
think it just confirmed because
sometimes we're tempted I think maybe
especially me to just like push a little
bit harder like for another Christmas
video and if we fill it in time that we
can release both before Christmas
you know it's such a good idea we can do
it we can push for your Halloween videos
you got some really great Halloween
videos yes really good was using
Christmases an example because that's
where we are now but I had some really
good Halloween video ideas that I really
wanted to do this is like really gung-ho
I think I like talker we'll do the next
year yeah videos are so off the wall
that no one's gonna do them but yeah so
like I I I'm often the one tempted to
like like well we can just push we can
just do it it but I think going through
that period again of being way over
scheduled kind of made me realize like
it's it's not worth it um and like in
the in the beginning when we started our
channel you kind of go into it yeah
that's that's why we did say yes to
everything but now we're at the point
where like it's it's we still have to
say has to a lot and we still push a lot
but we also have to be aware of the fact
that if you push too much then you're
gonna burn out and then you know that
what's the
long-term plan with that I think that
burnout is a word that's used for a lot
of different attitudes it is like when
you get tired of doing YouTube videos
kind of we're tired of creating content
for one reason or another but some
people get tired of the process of
creating content and that's not really
at all where we're at we still really
love making videos all of our videos we
love the process of all of it we really
want to do that more
the main thing like that that is
trending us towards burnout is not
having enough time for our business all
of the things that we're doing all the
projects that we're doing all of the
side things all of the business the life
all of that it's just like a lack of
time which adds a lot of pressure and
makes things stressful sometimes yeah
the only the only thing we're still
struggling with this time yes that's a
pretty big thing but like we haven't
burned out of the process of making
videos we still love what we're doing
we've been able to evolve our content to
the place where like we were doing
exactly what we want to do it's just too
much which is why we're like trying to
get caught up on all the stuff that's
been weighing on us that we put off yeah
do you want to play the game where we
are running our time it's quite like we
were we were wondering how long we're
going to talk about all this but we
think let's play one Madlib I want to
eat they're hard to edit well do - will
do - if the Christmas miracle will do -
okay game time pause for music
[Music]
okay give me a name
Juby give me an adjective fast give me a
body part claw and give me a noun
mouse okay
adjectives body part ears I'm just gonna
do ear because it needs to be seen okay
okay yeah verb ending an s ninjas I know
they're like for a plural noun which is
the next thing okay no I'll cuz cuz we
described julia is like ninja in around
it's like okay a verb a verb pooping at
some point the next plural noun to be
ninjas ninjas yes definitely mention
verb kill an insult an insult what was
the one from like the French guy in the
castle adjective adjective describes
smelly smelly one elderberries cuz I'm a
mage I know what you want adjectives I'm
trying to think of either Monty Python
or cat related adjectives Bernie okay
I'm a famous person um King Arthur
my reviver be a noun horses horse sorry
more specific a body part a body part
but adjectives did I do smelly I already
did smelly and fast noun fluffball
plural noun coconuts verb running wait
verb Ram that doesn't really work ok
I'll do another one on air it down a
verb that's like a feeling towards
someone a verb that's a feeling can't
use loved love angered ok verb I wrote
in here now in past tense great job k1
verb past tense spat ok
yeah mmm prepare yourself for the
classic Christmas Carol do be the fast
clawed Mouse this one's for you baby
Jew be the fast clawed mouse had a very
sneaky ear and if you ever saw it you
would even say it poops father ninja
used to kill and call him your mother
was a pastor they never let poor Jew be
plant any smelly elderberries then one
furry Christmas Eve King Arthur came to
say and they spat out with clean Jew be
the fast clawed mouse you'll go down in
history that's good sticking with the
theme works do you want me do you want
to do this one and I do the things ok
noun but ok
[Laughter]
no it's saying it's saying it's
inappropriate but it's the thing plural
noun
geese funny noise you gotta make a fart
noise okay adjectives hairy noun lip do
you know that they're in order now
you're kind of going for I can see you
building a story in your mind I'm not
really purposely trying to it's going
you with Marnie Python I'm just trying
to be fast grandpa no dance like like a
dance not like I know it's a verb an
verb with ending in ing twerking group
of people tick talkers funny expression
Koopa doodle do adjectives webbed noun
cobbler cobbler like as in like the
cobbler you eat or the cobbler that
makes shoes now hamster something you'd
say if you're in a rush hurry up your
buns uh noun art verb ending in ing
torturing oh my gosh
noun tooth adjective gassy was a good
one verb ending in ing frolicking
[Music]
body party armpit verb ending in ing was
I would not as many as your this very
ending in ing you tubing to the count
yes okay no all right porridge porridge
good no it's great
okay adjectives last one you're almost
there
you got this last one got a make it
count
Oh added too much pressure um I'm
looking around me and I'm not doing any
aspirin fluffy fluffy okay you already
use the word fluffy it's a versatile
thing and Juby is right here so what
about Harry we haven't used Harry I know
I did my lip cuz it so Harry
what about uncomfortable
sure because I'm feeling uncomfortable
okay I am feeling uncomfortable too this
song is gonna make me uncomfortable this
thing do you know the tune of this song
kind of I'm gonna try it I can help you
so everyone welcome to this beautiful
rendition of but ride just hear those
but geese farting farting - come on it's
hairy lip for but rides together with
grandpa ha ha outside the dance it's
working in the big talkers are calling
pooper didn't come on is web cobbler for
a butt ride together with hamster hurry
up your buns let's go let's look at the
art we're torturing into one
torturing in a wonderland of to hurry up
your buns is gassy just frolicking your
armpits
where are you tipping along with the
forage fairy land is good now ride
together with Bearpaw
that's bad bad friend it's like when
you're in traffic in you're like man
that guy's really riding my butt well
I'm glad some of the very last Christmas
carols and ever till next year probably
yes I do enjoy doing mad libs oh I do i
I wish I really think that there's
probably a website we're gonna type it
in well yeah generates it for you Kayla
made these custom yeah but but it'll
take just as long like for someone to
think of words and type them hmm it
won't make the process of the podcast
any faster it'll just make the prep
faster yeah that's true
yeah I guess it looks like anything that
adds any amount of editing it's so
hypocritical too because like Caitlin s
edit a lot and I'm like oh my gosh I
have to deal with ten minutes of this
game where I have to do all these cuts
okay that's all you're faster maybe you
won't have to cut I'm soaking I'm still
gonna be cutting everything all the
pauses just make it like I'm comfortable
listening to it again I'm like alright
we know that brings us to thing of the
week
I still have the tune all right so my
thing of the week is something you're
gonna be seeing in this week's video
coming out soon we have a holiday
special and in it we use a secret new
ingredient a secret tool that we're
gonna use in the future it's hot glue
but it's unlike any hot glue you've ever
seen it's solid opaque white it's
beautiful it's amazing it's different
too
it dries like a hard plastic and it's
shiny it's shiny it's it's a really
really interesting material that I'm
like oh yeah I'm just like legit very
intrigued by this material I'm wondering
like can we make molds with it tiny mold
fill or can we fill molds casting
material oh and then you just have it's
like your own injection molding so
you're not an injection molding it's so
interesting and it comes in other colors
too we bought a pig white but there's
like a bunch of colored hot glues what
if what if we got like moldable hot glue
guns and we squeeze them all in and we
mixed it like a marble and then like it
was like a marbled material oh we got to
do that soon what are we gonna make we
just gave away our idea there's like
hundreds of people thousands even too
sometimes huh cool well don't steal our
idea which is not I'm not even sure what
the idea is yet it's not fully but it's
gonna be cool I'm really excited about
for the future the white house glue is
pretty awesome
okay killin what's your thing of the
week I think of the week is Peaberry
coffee wow what can I do something wait
wait wait wait witch okay so I really
like coffee but I've never paid
attention to like what types of coffee I
like has just been like I don't know and
pay attention like dark roast or medium
roast or what kind of bean it was yeah
but we had one that was like super super
good okay
I'm using my sound board my name is live
so don't have to edit them in later we
found one that was really really good
and it was like one of our favorite
coffees and we used it with the espresso
machine which was the past thing of the
week of mine but we were like okay this
coffee is so good what kind of coffee is
this even because we should try to
figure that out and try to like learn
what coffee we like yeah so we didn't
really know what made it a coffee that
we really liked and we looked at the
packaging on the one that we really
liked and we notice it's had P berry on
there which is a term that I hadn't ever
heard before so I was like maybe that's
something special about this specific
one and we looked it up and it is like a
very specific type of bean and so we
found one on Amazon because we wanted
one that was like really easy to reorder
very consistent and always available
yeah so like yeah we wanted something
that we could like order and have within
two days basically that we could always
get and we took a risk we ordered one
and we tried it out it's so dang tasty
it's what's the brand we get I'll pull
it up I'll pull it up and the link will
be in the description if you want to
link to that like direct one Stonestreet
so it's a or kits Stonestreet and
there's a specific PB airy and it's a
specific thing it's like an Zane E&P
berry anyways links in the description
it's so tasty
it's so good and you know we've only
brewed it in our fancy espresso machine
which isn't that fancy I mean it's
different like brewing it and an
espresso machine vers brewing in like a
Quadra or fog drip or like we we told
your parents about the espresso machine
because we were like raving about it and
your mom really wanted to try it so they
brought over like the coffee they
usually have which is like a Starbucks
top dark roast
they said it tasted different and I've
had I've had the Starbucks dark roast
before just like in a normal coffee
maker it's just like you know it's good
like what you know just good basic
coffee um and I had it in our espresso
machine and it was like was really
strong so strong like released
so it could be that like the pea berry
maybe it's like less bitter or less
acidic or something and so like when you
have it in the espresso maker it's not
as overpowering maybe it would be like
weaker panic in a normal coffee maker
I'm not sure all I could say is like an
espresso machine is real but also I I
for the longest time have been okay with
coffee
I generally kind of like it but this
combination of this espresso machine and
this coffee has turned me into like a
coffee person I love my coffee now I
love having it in the morning with
Caitlyn we like wake up we have our
coffee we sit at our desks we go through
our to-do list we like review Caitlyn's
edit from the past day or a review
Gaming edits and we just like passed the
coffee back and forth this is one cup of
coffee yeah in total but like it's it's
tasty tasty alright guys well this this
is it
we won't see you for another year we
won't see you for another decade I mean
no no that sounds like we're taking a
year or a decade off we won't in this
decade we will see you in this year okay
we will see you next year
make sure to subscribe maturity make
sure to subscribe make sure to LIKE make
sure to send this to your family or else
podcast Barry's spending the lowest
podcast and death did you have something
you wanted to say is the podcast Barry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah yeah that's what you're recording
sneaky crazy what are you gonna do with
this